okay so you know how some movies have a
decent amount of VFX but it's like kind
of hidden and maybe you don't realize it
until later yeah Ant-Man and the WASP is
the opposite of that I took a look at
some of the clips they put out showing
the very crazy VFX they used and it gave
me a whole new appreciation for this
super fun movie one of the first VFX you
see in the movie is a flashback to the
1980s but instead of having like I
should wash jeans and doing Rubik's
Cubes or whatever it's mostly about
showing younger versions of the
characters they wanted to make us really
believe it was Michael Douglas and
Michelle Pfeiffer playing Hope's parents
so they de-aged them it's not the first
time Marvel has used it but it's still
hella cool to see someone get the clock
turned back on them by like 30 or 40
years and it's just a sprinkling of the
Cool Tech they used on various
characters like ghosts more on that
later anyway in this clip you can see
Hank Pym AKA Michael Douglas get turned
back or as the more Marvel ahead of
effects called it they yungify him see
all those little dots on his face those
aren't zits you can see how they
literally shave years off of his face
they did the same thing on Michelle
Pfeiffer making her look like she's
ready to shoot the children nobody
wanted and yes that's a TV movie from
1981 that I just found when I Googled
early Michelle Pfeiffer movies the next
time we really get to see the killer VFX
in action is a scene when the WASP AKA
hope Pym is fighting bad guys in the
kitchen of a restaurant they use what
are called Frasier lenses not to get too
Tech nerdy here but basically they allow
you to focus on any spot you choose with
most lenses you have to like pick where
the focus is usually it's closer to the
camera and then other stuff is blurry or
you can focus on the background and the
foreground is blurry basically if you've
ever tried to take a pic of your friends
and someone is in the back of the room
and looks blurry AF you know but these
Frasier lenses make it so they can focus
on literally anything in the frame that
means they can throw in Crazy VFX fight
moves and size changes and it all still
looks like really realistic this scene
includes a killer sequence with a flying
knife and a miniature hope literally
running along the blade as you can see
there wasn't even a knife in the shot
the actor just did like a throwing
motion excellent mime work my dude and
then you can see how the wasp and the
knife were added as CG now it's no
surprise that a person the size of a bug
dancing along a knife blade was done
with VFX but I was surprised to find out
even some of the food on the counters
with CG like those tomatoes that are
smashed up when the bad guy is trying to
kill hope totally VFX when I heard about
the VFX they used on ghost it was a
little bit of a face pop if I'm being
honest not because of anything they did
but because I figured it was a lot more
high-tech than how they actually did it
turns out they basically the actress do
a bunch of takes of all of her movements
and Avi if you move around in the same
space you're never gonna hit the same
exact position twice you'll get close
but like unless your robot your body is
going to be in slightly different spots
each time so they essentially just chose
one of them as the hero shot aka the one
where she looks like a solid person and
then they just included a ton more of
them but like hazy versions of it so it
looked like she was in 20 different
places at the same time and if they
saved any money with the relatively
low-tech VFX for ghost they definitely
spent it immediately on the VFX for the
ants I mean if you call a movie Ant-Man
you're gonna want to have some real ants
in the sequel they clearly upped their
ant budget by like 10 times and it turns
out the folks at cinecyte who did all
the VFX for Ant-Man and the WASP got to
nerd out about real ants they watched
tons of ant footage to mirror how they
walk and move so they'd look right at
home working in a lap there was also the
weird problem that trap jaw ants look
like really smooth in real life they
would end up looking like plastic toys
in the final rendering of the movie so
they had to I don't know unsmooth them
with CG they also went above and beyond
with these ants giving them all slightly
different body shapes and even different
coloring depending on how old each ant
was or what species it was or maybe how
much spray tan they had put on that
morning ants needed that glow up too you
guys Ant-Man even gotta glow up towards
the end of the movie though it's more
like a blow up because he became a giant
see what I did there anyway Ant-Man is
like the size of a building and he has
to go get the miniaturized lab from
Sunny Birch for starters there's a fun
look at the lab being pulled up by
strings that'll later be turned into
ant-man's giant fingers in post but what
surprised me the most is how detailed
and labor-intensive this scene was and a
lot of it was working on the water
itself I guess if you have a giant man
splashing around you got to get the
water right or it'll look fake but check
out the amount of detail feels like
they're almost going droplet to droplet
here and then there's all the nuances of
the sky and the Fairy and then putting
big old Paul Rudd and the water next to
the boat they even went into a crazy
amount of detail for a shot when he
falls underwater they took their time to
painstakingly make the water look just
as muddy and murky as it is in real life
but then when he falls in it churns
everything so much you probably would
never notice that they made it
accurately murky still it's wild to hear
about the level of detail they put in
and speaking of insane levels of detail
the quantum realm sequence came towards
the end of the movie so you know they
were feeling the pressure to nail it and
you know what I think they did the whole
point of the sequence was that Hank was
diving deeper and deeper into different
areas of it as he got smaller so they
not only had to make it look cool yet
somehow realistic but they also had to
create new looks for each new layer he
went down into the CG bugs were actually
modeled in one of the layers after
actual microbial creatures that
scientists have seen in real life and
now I will probably see them in my
nightmares thanks Marvel then as he goes
to the most subatomic level of the
quantum layers they were pretty much
able to just go off of their imagination
because spoiler no one has ever been
that small in real life the whole
sequence was animated with a lighting
scheme from a prism and they were using
coral reefs as another reference point
they also looked at real viruses through
a microscope and copied some of the
color schemes they saw then in the VFX
they put those colors and textures onto
the landscape that Hank was moving
around it and yes in case you're
wondering the whole scene is totes
supposed to make you feel uncomfy it
worked on me that's for sure do you
think it's better when VFX are super
obvious like a person shrinking and
growing or more subtle do you ever
notice when VFX are looking kind of
janky let us know in the comments
section